The thinking of trying these homeopathic drops called slender ease to help with 10 to 15
pound weight gain from hormone blockers and menopause and fatigue. The many other things that come
with menopause. The ingredients are ammonium bromantum. I'm not going to read all these homeopathic
names and it has. So every all these homeopaths, these are all homeopaths. If this is a product in
it, not a homeopath, then I would not approve of that. So this is methylcopylobe. It sounds like
the homeopaths end here. And then these are supplements. So these are, this is a homeopath,
Cali, Phosphorochum. These are all homeopaths here. So understand homeopathy. Homeopathy is
using a frequency of a substance to stimulate your body in traditional homeopathy. It's to stimulate
your body to heal something. And there's different forms of homeopathy. You may take like,
okay, you're using our radiation homeopath or radiogen homeopath. That's the homeopath of
radium to help pull radiation out of your body. Or if you're going to take mercury as a homeopath,
you're using the frequency of mercury to stimulate your body to release mercury and to get
mercury out of your body. That's how homeopaths work. Can you hurt yourself with homeopaths?
You could have a herx type reaction because you're dumping toxins, but that's really about it.
You're not going to really, you can't really hurt yourself with the homeopath other than that. What
you can, I mean, that can be harmful, you can feel sick, but you're not going to, you know,
do dare, you're not going to, there's no least little dose of a homeopath. Whereas there's a least
little dose of everything else, exactly homeopath. So homeopath is the frequency of a substance.
Okay, so it looks like these are homeopaths. I have no trouble with homeopaths. So you can take
homeopaths. No problems. These are not homeopaths. These are nutrients. So methyl cobala
bead is a methylated B12. Ashwagandha is a nutrient that can help calm you. It's an adaptogenic
herb. So it's rodiola. Biotid is a nutrient. Rose hips is a source of vitamin C. So I guess I
would have maybe a little bit of problem with that. But if it's just the rose hips, then it's just a
food-based vitamin C. So it's probably not a lot there. So I don't really have a problem with that.
I just have a problem with this because this is a methyl cobala bead. So this is a methylated
substance that methylated B12 that you really don't want to have. And I don't remember who asked
this question. So I mean, it might be different if the person is like completely doing great with
their cancer. And this is a very, very low dose of methyl cobala bead. Then I guess I would,
you know, when you're going to take it for a short period of time, I don't have problem with that. But
if it's a different person who is dealing with their active cancer right now, you don't want those
methyl groups.